last time i introduced the task of
relation extraction i
described the corpus and the kb that
we're going to use
and i proposed a precise formulation of
our prediction problem
so now let's talk about how we're going
to measure success on this problem we
need to define a quantitative evaluation
that can drive a process of iterative
development
in this section i'm going to first make
a connection to the software engineering
principle of test driven development
then i'm going to explain how we'll
split our data into training and
evaluation data i'll do a brief
refresher on precision recall and f
measure
and i'll review the distinction between
microaveraging and macro averaging
and by the end we'll know exactly how
we're going to measure success
when you start working on a new machine
learning problem it's very tempting to
jump in and start building models right
away because
you're bursting with ideas and you can't
wait to get started
but
whoa nelly that's like driving
cross-country without a map there's
gonna be lots of forks in the road and
you won't know which way to go
there's a better way
software engineering we use test driven
development first write the tests
and then write code and iterate until it
passes the tests
in model engineering we can use a
similar paradigm first implement a
quantitative evaluation specify your
evaluation data set
choose your evaluation metric build a
test harness that takes a model and
generates a score
then when you start building models you
can he'll climb on this score and at
those forks in the road where you could
do it this way or that way your
quantitative evaluation will tell you
which way to go
now whenever we build a model from data
it's good practice to partition the data
into multiple splits
minimally a training split and a test
split
actually here we'll go a bit further and
we'll define multiple splits first we'll
have a tiny split with just one percent
of the data
having a tiny split is super useful and
i encourage you to adopt this practice
whenever you take on a new prediction
problem during the early stages of
development you can use the tiny split
as training data or test data or both
and your experiments will run super fast
of course your quantitative evaluations
will be pretty much meaningless but it's
a great way to quickly flush out any
bugs in your setup
then we'll have the train split with 74
percent of the data this is the data
that we'll usually use for model
training
then the dev split with 25 of the data
we'll use this as test data for
intermediate evaluations during
development
and for the bake off we're also going to
have a separate test split
but you won't have access to it so we
won't talk about it here
there's one complication we need to
split both the corpus and the kb
we want each relation to appear in both
the training data and the test data so
that we can assess how well we've
learned how how each relation is
expressed in natural language
but ideally we'd like to have any given
entity
appear in only one split
otherwise we might be leaking
information from the training data into
the test data
in an ideal world each split would have
its own hermetically sealed universe of
entities and both the corpus and the kb
for that split would refer only to those
entities so for example you might have a
new world corpus whose examples mention
only new world entities like elon musk
and bill gates and steve jobs
and a new world kb which contains only
triples about the same new world
entities
and then an old old world corpus that
talks about daniel eck and jack ma and
pony ma
and a corresponding old world kb
if we had this then we could achieve a
really clean separation between train
and test data with no overlap in
entities
but in practice the world is strongly
entangled and this ideal is hard to
achieve so instead we're going to
approximate the ideal
i think i won't dwell on the details but
we've written the code for you to
achieve a good enough split
in particular the dataset class provides
a method called build splits which lets
you specify split names
and
proportions and a random seed
and it just returns a map from split
names to data sets each containing a
corpus and a kb
so now that we have our splits we need
to choose an evaluation metric
we've formulated our problem as binary
classification and the standard metrics
for binary classification are precision
and recall so here's an example where we
have a hundred problem instances
the rows of this table represent the
actual labels 88 are labeled false and
only 12 are labeled true
so this is a skewed distribution
the columns of this table represent the
labels predicted by our model so 95 are
predicted to be false and 5 true
now there are 89 instances where the
predicted label agrees with the actual
label so the accuracy of this model is
but accuracy is not a great evaluation
metric especially when you have a skewed
distribution like this
because even a model that ignores the
data
and always guesses false can get 88
accuracy just by always guessing false
so instead of accuracy we look at
precision which says of the instances
that are predicted to be true what
proportion are actually true
and recall which says of the instances
which are actually true what proportion
are predicted to be true
so that's great precision and recall are
really useful
but
having two evaluation metrics is often
inconvenient if we're considering a
change to our model which improves
precision
but degrades recall
should we take it
in order to drive an iterative
development process it's useful to have
a single metric
on which to hillclimb
so for binary classification the
standard answer is the f1 score which is
the harmonic mean
of precision and recall
the harmonic mean is
the reciprocal of the arithmetic mean
the average of the reciprocals and it's
always less than the arithmetic mean
it's pessimistic in the sense that it's
always closer to the lower number
so the arithmetic mean of 60 and 25
is sorry the harmonic mean of 60 and 25
percent is 35.3
now the f1 score gives equal weight
to precision and recall
but depending on the application they
might not be of equal importance
in relation extraction we probably care
more about precision than recall
and that's because adding an invalid
triple to the kb
is more harmful
than failing to add a valid one
so instead we could use the f measure
which is a generalization of f1 it's a
weighted harmonic mean of precision and
recall and this parameter beta controls
how much more importance you place on
recall
than on precision
so let's say that in a particular
evaluation you have high precision 80
percent uh and low recall 20
the f1 score gives equal weight to
precision and recall so its value is 32
percent
if we set beta equal to
0.5
we're giving more weight to precision
so the value is 50 percent
if we set beta equal to 2 we're giving
more weight to recall so the value is
23.5 percent
in relation extraction precision is more
important than recall
so let's go with f 0.5 as our evaluation
metric okay another issue that comes up
in evaluation scenarios like this is
whether to use
micro averaging or macro averaging
we're going to compute precision recall
and f score separately for each relation
but in order to drive iterative
development
we'd like to have summary metrics which
aggregate across all of the relations
and there are two possible ways to do
this microaveraging gives equal weight
to each problem instance
which means that it gives more weight to
relations with more instances
macro averaging just gives equal weight
to each relation
so let me show you an illustration of
this this is an artificial example where
i have just three relations
and the contains relation has ten times
as many instances as the other two
relations it also has the highest f
score
when i compute the microaverage and the
macro average well the micro average
gives equal weight to each problem
instance
so it gives a lot more weight to the
contains relation and the result is that
the microaveraged f-score is very close
to the f-score for contains
whereas the macro average gives equal
weight to each relation
and so it's just right in the middle of
this range
um the micro average f score is probably
not what we want
because the number of instances per
relation
is kind of an accident of our data
collection methodology
and it's not like we believe that the
contains relation is more important than
the other relations it just happens to
be more numerous in the data that we
collected
so we're going to use macro averaging so
that we don't overweight large relations
so if you put it all together the bottom
line is that with every evaluation we're
going to report lots of metrics but
there's one metric that we're going to
focus on and this will be our figure of
merit it's the one number that we're
going to be hill climbing on and we're
choosing as our figure of merit the
macro averaged f 0.5 score
you